Assalamualaikum,
warahmatullah wabarakatuh.
I want to thank you for joining me for this short series in this blessed month
of Ramadan.
Inshallah ta'ala, this month is about spiritual elevation.
It's about deeper understanding
of our relationship with Allah subhana wa ta'ala and with the Rasul sallallahu alaihi wa sallam.
A deep part of Ramadan is gaining deeper insight
into how Allah subhana wa ta'ala blesses us, how we are to get close to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala,
and deeper understanding of who we are as people and who we should aspire to be
as believers.
Inshallah, over these next few videos, I'm going to be taking you through
a well-known collection of short, beautiful phrases
that have been crafted and written by none other than Ibn Ata'illah al-Iskandari.
This book is known as al-Hikam, which just means these aphorisms or these short sayings that
are filled with wisdom
and a lot for us to think about.
The words are short, but the meanings are deep.
And inshallah,
I thank you for joining me for these gems of reflection
and depth
uh through the insight of Ibn Ata'illah al-Iskandari.
So, with that said, inshallah, we're going to move into our first one for today, inshallah
ta'ala.
Ibn Ata'illah, he says,
Rubbama waradat al-dhuluma alaik
li yu'arrifaka qadra manna bihi
alaik.
The Imam, he says
that sometimes
darkness will come over our heart.
May- maybe it's a sin that we fall into.
Uh maybe it's a emotional state that we're feeling.
Um any type of darkness will come over our hearts.
And we struggle with wondering why we are experiencing that.
We struggle to wonder and understand
what is the wisdom behind it, right?
Um there's a hadith that is quite beautiful.
In which the Rasul alayhi salaat wa salaam, he said that the believer's affair is quite
unique.
If hardship comes,
the believer is patient, and that is good.
And if ease comes, the believer is grateful, and that is also good.
What the Prophet alayhi salaat wa salaam was teaching us in this Hadith is that
it's all good, as we used to say.
It's all good.
Meaning whatever we're going through, there is something there for us to notice.
Something for us to learn.
Some way for us to grow.
And so, in this aphorism, in this Hikam,
the Imam, he says,
that
sometimes darkness will come over your heart.
It comes in different ways.
But why?
He says one of the reasons is
li yu'arrifaka qadra ma manna bihi alayk.
So that he can make you recognize, so that he can make you see
the value of the blessings that he has given you before.
Now, there's a few ways to look at this.
There's a saying, you know, like faqidu shay, like a person that doesn't know one realizes
the blessing of something until it is taken away, until it is gone.
What the Imam is saying here is
sometimes
you may fall into a sin.
But the reason you fell into the sin is that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala wants you
to realize how blessed you were when you were not caught in that sin.
Maybe you go through a moment of some slight depression or some anxiety.
But what is a deeper reason?
Or what What is it different a deeper wisdom?
Is that you walk away from that appreciating
the moments
of ease,
of of mental well-being.
And here's what's even more profound.
Our life is always going through ups and downs.
That is the nature of the believer's life.
And that's why I quoted the Hadith of the Rasul earlier on.
But here's the deal.
You may be in a dark moment right now.
But the truth about life is there's constant change.
That's the only
uh constant of life is change, quite ironically.
So, when the blessings do return,
now you have a deeper appreciation for them.
And so, as scholars have said, they said subhanallah,
when you look at it from this perspective,
the nikmah, hardship, has now become a ni'mah, a blessing.
So, the idea is we don't want to fall into sin.
But when we fall into sin, we have to have the ability to bounce back.
And in order to bounce back, you have to see what was God teaching me through
this. What was I supposed to get out of this?
And that's what the Imam is teaching us.
He says, "Rubbama,
sometimes,
darkness will come over the heart.
And the reason that that may be coming
is so that you can gain a deeper appreciation
for the blessings that he has been constantly giving you before this hardship.
And here's where it's so profound.
The blessings that will come after this hardship.
Our job is to become people that don't lose hope when the hardship comes.
That we don't feel hopeless.
We don't feel forsaken.
But we realize that there's a blessing
in
every situation that we have gone through.
So, if you're going through a hardship right now,
struggling with a sin, struggling to get back on your deen, maybe it's a family difficulty,
remember that this allows you to become someone of appreciation
and recognition.
Now, last thing I'll say before we end today's session,
there's no greater blessing
than to be someone who recognizes the blessings that they have.
That is the greatest blessing because to be a grateful person, shaqir,
you first have to recognize the blessings.
And if we look throughout the entire Quoran, and if we look at the entire
Sunnah of the Rasul, why did he do what he did?
Why did he spend nights in prayer?
He said one reason.
Li akuna abdan shaqura, so that I can become a person of gratitude.
Everything we're doing in this month of Ramadan is based in gratitude.
And there's no way to be grateful unless you value the blessings you have.
And sometimes you only value
the light
because of the dark.
May Allah bless you in your moments
and bring you light, contentment, and blessings in this blessed month of Ramadan.
Salam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.